[Music]
foreign
Ty Goodman's general manager and VP of
engineering for databases at Google
cloud and I'm excited to share with you
what's next for Builders and data
engineers at Google Cloud our mission is
to accelerate every organization's
ability to digitally transform
and a large part of that is helping
customers innovate faster with the
unified open and intelligent data
platform
we do this by focusing on four key areas
let's start with the first Focus area
creating a unified and integrated data
Cloud if you're operational and
analytical data
the way we've built our core services
such as Cloud spanner bigtable alloy DB
MPEG query is truly differentiated
building on this customers need to have
easy movement of data within the data
cloud
we heard you and that's why we announced
in preview data stream for bigquery
data stream for bigquery provides easy
replication of data from operational
database sources such as lodb postgres
MySQL and Oracle directly into bigquery
this is special because we worked
closely with the bigquery team to
develop an optimized integration to
replicate database updates in real time
at very low latency
setup is just a few simple clicks the
second Focus area is our continued
commitment to open source and Open
Standards for increased flexibility and
portability without vendor lock-in
we offer many services that are fully
compatible with the most popular open
source engines such as MySQL postgres
and redis we're focused on making Google
Cloud the best place to run your
postgres workloads
we offer you not one not two but three
fully managed services that support the
postgres interface
first Cloud SQL for postgres
it is our Enterprise ready fully managed
relational database service
you get the same experience of Open
Source postgres with the strong
manageability availability and security
capabilities of cloud SQL
and you can use the same service apis to
also manage your MySQL and SQL Server
databases second alloy DBS are fully
managed postgres compatible database
service ready for your top tier
workloads and for modernizing your
legacy proprietary databases in the
cloud
in our performance tests alloyodb is
more than four times faster than open
source postgres and two times faster
than Amazon's comparable postgres
compatible service for transactional
workloads
it also delivers up to 100 times faster
analytical queries than standard
postgres and finally we've also added a
postgres interface for spanner our
transformative relational database with
unlimited global scale strong external
consistency and up to five nines
availability
with the postgres interface for spanner
developers can take advantage of
familiar tools and skills from the
postgres ecosystem
and to further democratize access to
spanner we recently announced a free
trial to give Builders an easy way to
try out spanner at no cost
get started building with spanner today
the third Focus area is around how we
are infusing Ai and ml across
data-driven workloads we use Ai and ml
across our database Technologies to make
our services more intelligent
capabilities such as Cloud SQL cost
recommenders and alloy DB autopilot
enable dbas and devops teams to manage
performance and capacity for large
fleets of databases
in addition to infusing Ai and ml into
our databases we're providing
integration with vertex AI our Ai and ml
platform to enable model inferencing
directly within the database transaction
I'm therefore excited to announce today
in preview the integration of vertex AI
with spanner
you can now use a SQL query in spanner
to call a model and vertex AI
with this integration both alloy DB and
now spanner can simply call vertex AI
models using SQL in operational
transactions allowing data scientists to
build their models easily in vertex Ai
and developers to access these models
using the SQL query language our final
Focus area is around empowering Builders
to be more productive with Innovative
one-of-a-kind developer experiences
we've introduced Cloud SQL query
insights for postgres and MySQL in
addition we make Cloud SQL cost
recommenders generally available and
introduce postgres system insights in
preview
today we're excited to announce the
preview of security and performance
recommenders for cloud SQL thank you
enjoy the rest of next
[Music]